welcome to it how did you ever wanted
something so much that you had to go for
it no matter what it took
Atlanta is filled with such rich and
diverse artistry
but I do what I'm gonna do what it takes
your mother's been arrested this was not
the plan we don't have a choice maybe
all this talking about high water this
is a mission to get the art back to the
people the chance I've been busting my
ass for my entire life I at least have
to try hello when you come here the same
for Hamlet just you jump out in that
circle you better be fired
sometimes opportunities of a lifetime
are too expensive for people like me you
didn't mean to lie I just wanted to
dance you ain't from these streets watch
yourself
you guys think that this is gonna be the
last of me you have another thing coming
I met someone today he's fine
I've never actually said it out loud
let me tell you something hiding ain't
help I need one additional dancing is
not just what I do it's it's a matter of
life and death
College is not gonna get me where I want
to go high water is you dread with that
show who wants to be a meaning
my father answer is hail this is why I'm
here you might run how old you're the
one who gets to dance every day and live
my dream baby don't want that did you
think about that this is your golden
ticket make sure you're ready to seize
that moment when it come
[Music]
how's this it's a bellyful not the kind
of pull that I was gonna putting
everybody
[Music]
you